now
[Music]
every year the nutcracker wows audiences
at the smith center during the holidays
but like so many other things this year
the pandemic has pushed the las vegas
production off the stage
yeah unfortunately but sherry there is a
new exhibit it's given us a rare look at
the costumes
and the set pieces things you never
really get to see up close
but hector mejia is and he's live at the
discovery children's museum with that
hey hector you look good
hey there i have officially become a
museum
exhibit check this out this is actually
pretty heavy and this is a real costume
used in the nutcracker production here
in las vegas and joining us live we have
roy kaiser
with the nevada theater ballet correct
nevada ballet theater
valley theater i had i had a gut feeling
i had a
little little a little twisted good
morning how are you doing i'm great how
are you
i'm good i feel like royalty with this
on what is this
you look like royalty that is uh uh
the character is drosselmeyer and he is
clara claire is the main character in
the nutcracker he's
uh clara's godfather so that's his
jacket he wears that
into the party scene where's it
throughout the ballet actually and this
is
really unique thank you guys for letting
me actually wear it
well i'm looking at this as an audition
i think maybe
next season when we're back on stage i'm
going to be calling you
i'll get on the waiting list so these
these costumes are so cool tell us about
all of the work that goes into this a
lot of these are hand-painted
oh they are i mean the costumes are were
designed by a very
well-known costume designer by the name
of sandra woodall
and they were they were built in new
york
at a very well-known uh costume shop
and they're very very unique
really one of a kind every single design
a lot of hand paint painted elements a
lot of detail
and on that note this is a really unique
opportunity these
costumes all of these set pieces are
normally either in storage or already at
the smith center ready for the shows
right we would you know in a
non-non-pandemic year we would be
running the show at the smith center as
we speak so
uh yet to have the uh to have the
opportunity for people to come
in and see these costumes the actual
costumes from the performance
up close we have a number of the set
elements here as well
and then we also try to tell the story
of the ballet a little bit through video
and some signage throughout that just
kind of helps
propel the story and it's really
engaging for all of the parents and
children coming out here to
have something to do for the holidays i
hope so yeah yeah we wanted to uh we
wanted to make something special there's
so many things that are on hold so
we're just really thankful for the
opportunity to partner with dcm
and bring these out it's really neat so
let's go over to the details it all
opens tomorrow
the exhibit is open until january 3rd
correct your admission
ticket gets you into this exhibit hall
and it's uh
two weeks only limited time limited time
two weeks only
but a very special experience we'll also
have a photo opportunity
for people to come through if they want
a little momento so
yeah yeah hopefully a lot of people come
out and see it that's really cool thank
you for having us we'll be talking a bit
more about this straight ahead at six
o'clock for now
i'm gonna go back into the birdcage stay
there and i guess i'll spend my weekend
here so you guys want to come on down
and see me
i'll be right there in that birth cage
reporting live hector mejia
8 news now